In this video, we're going to talk about how to set up
two-way communication so the receiver can
also send message back to the sender.
Now, to do that,
let's take a look at what it is being set up right now.
The sender, you will see
the two-way communication related part
are all being commented in the yellow comment box.
So first, at begin play,
we will check if this instance
should be in two-way communication.
If it is two-way for the sender,
remember that before that the sender only
has a OSC client targeting the receiver,
so the sender doesn't have any way to receive messages.
So to allow the sender to also able to receive messages,
we want the sender to create an OSC server.
Now, because I know that my Internet
is fairly simple, I'm going to just leave this part blank,
so it will try to grab the first IP it has on this device.
Remember to use the same port
that is going to send the message back in.
Right now, we just used OSC port variable,
which we can set in the launch parameter later.
Now, I set the name of the OSC server to also be server.
If you remember, on the receiver side,
we also have the same server name here.
It's a bad practice,
so we actually should try to name them something else.
But if you remember,
a sender is never a receiver,
so usually there will not be
the same named OSC server component at the same instance.
That is actually fine.
But still, if we want to make sure
the server name is never the same,
we can also use sender IP address,
for example, to be the name.
So unless there's same instance from the same IP,
the name will never be duplicated.
So now we need the sender's own server as a different variable,
and we want the server to react to
all the event in the same way the receiver receives it.
So now we want to bind it to the OSC boundary received,
and also bind it to OSC message received.
So when that happened,
we actually wanted to just do
the same thing as what the receiver is doing.
So remember at begin play,
we are getting the receiver on the same level as a reference.
We're now going to get that reference and
just fire the same event in OSC receiver.
That's it. Now we make sure the sender also has
a server is able to listening to combing OSC messages,
and whenever there is a message or a bundle combing,
it is doing the same reaction
we wanted to do on the receiver side.
Now let's go to our receiver side
and move on to the two-way part.
At begin play, it is checking if it is a two-way communication.
If it is, it want to also be able to point
to the sender and send message back to the sender.
So for that, we want to create an OSC client.
The OSC client will have to target to
the sender IP address where we can set inside launch parameter.
The same, we're going to use the OSC port here.
We're going to save the client as a OSC client.
On the sender side,
we want to save the client and we also
want to save it as a variable on the OSC sender blueprint.
Now, in order to send the messages,
just so that we don't need to duplicate all the events,
again, we will go back to our sender part.
Now, if we go to the send messages event here,
we will see that when we're sending the message,
we are selecting our target based
on if the instance being played is a sender.
Now, if I am a sender,
I know the OSC client I want to target is the first one.
Because this is the first one I saved
before I do the two-way communication thing,
this is the receiver's target.
But if the instance being played is not a sender,
it is a receiver,
then we know receiver want to use this target.
It's targeting the sender.
Now, this might feels a little bit complicated,
but just know that we are just reusing the same set of logic.
Based on who is sending,
we will target destinations here.
We know that this part is already taken care
of for the example events here.
We just want to grab this logic,
we will copy and put into the new two events we just created.
We know that OSC client here,
so we know that the send event here is working for
one-way communication to make
it working on two-way communication.
I will replace the target to be this one.
Same thing for the bundle,
I'm just going to drag down here,
delete this node, like so.
Now we're ready to run the two-way testing.
Now just before we make a package,
I'll just connect back to where it should be,
so make sure we are using the launch parameter,
like so, save it.
Now we already finished
working on the two-way communication.
Now let's move on to package this project.